u.s women's national soccer team the
other day
they took a knee before their game with
sweden in fact the swedish team also
took a knee all to protest
racism the the rolling art just gets
longer and longer these days because
there is so much
racism so basically as they always do
before their games because america sucks
but don't worry
america sucks and they're representing
america so i just have a general
objections the idea that you kneel for
the national anthem
and that you kneel before your games to
protest how much your country blows and
then you represent your country
nope nope just as if you were a member
of the new york yankees
and then before every yankees game you
stood up and you're like yankees suck
i think everybody would be justified in
hoping that you were traded i think the
u.s women's national soccer team
making the statement that america is
horrible and systemically racist and
terrible when they become rich and
famous for playing a sport that
literally no one watches
outside of the world cup they've tried
several times to create a sustainable
women's soccer league in the united
states it has never been particularly
sustainable
it has survived on subsidies that is
pretty much all
the average attendance of these games is
basically the immediate family
okay so the u.s women's national soccer
team these women who become rich and
famous
by playing a sport that originally was
basically established by title ix
uh they now they spend their days
kneeling
for the laws and for the money and then
they lost so the other day they lost to
sweden
just before their 90-minute contest on
wednesday morning the british women's
soccer team knelt
alongside their chilean opponents so
this is now become like a worldwide
thing
all of the teams are kneeling great
can you feel the world getting better
the world's getting better because we
all kneel about how racist we are it's
pretty great
okay but the the us women's soccer team
then lost they proceeded to lose three
nothing to the swedes when it came to
match action
the top ranked team in the world the usa
suffered a surprising 3-0 defeat to the
fifth ranked swedish team
that was their first loss since january
2019 breaking a 44 game unbeaten streak
the decision to neo was motivated
according to yahoo news as a protest
against racism
and other forms of discrimination it
lasted about 10 seconds before an empty
tokyo stadium
so this is all very exciting stuff i
gotta say i'm rooting pretty hard
against the us women's national soccer
team
because i don't think they are patriotic
okay just because they were the flag
does not make them patriotic so what you
get from the left is
oh so you want the u.s to lose no i want
the u.s to win by having people who are
unpatriotic lose how about that
i think if you spend your day like megan
rapinoe making millions of dollars by
claiming that you're a victim of
american society
and you kneel for the national anthem
and you think the american flag stands
for racism and bigotry and homophobia
and then somebody is stupid enough to
give you an american jersey to wear i
think me rooting against you is not
rooting against the american flag i
think it's me rooting against the person
who roots against the american flag it
really is that simple
in fact i think that there should be a
widespread
acknowledgment by the u.s olympic
committee that people who protest the
american flag should not represent the
american flag
if you don't like the american flag i'm
not sure why you should be wearing it
again i go back to the yankees example
if you hate the yankees and you think
the yankees suck
you're going to protest the yankees
before every game i don't think the
yankees should sign you
we'll get more into this in just one
second first there are a thousand
reasons why protecting my home matters
to me i have three big ones they are
seven
five and one and they are just awesome
but here's the thing i need to keep an
eye on them because they are crazy
they're small children
ring helps me do all of that stuff if
somebody stops by or something is going
on outdoors around the house ring
lets me know it's peace of mind anytime
knowing my home is protected
ring has a special offer right now but
ring.com forward slash ben
it is the perfect way to start your ring
experience one of the best benefits you
install the products yourself
the process is hassle free your whole
home is protected with easy to install
indoor and outdoor cams and
get this the cams work seamlessly with
ring alarm you see what's happening from
anywhere
all in one very simple app it's never
been more important to have a reliable
home security system
i'm pleased my family and i can keep an
eye on our home no matter where we are
right from our phone and
know when those packages are delivered i
love a ring security system
anytime i'm out of town i still know
exactly what's going on which is
fabulous protect your home
anytime anywhere with ring alarm go to
ring.com for a special offer on a ring
alarm security kit today
you can build the system that's right
for your home have it up and running in
just minutes that is ring.com
once more ring.com i'm not gonna make
any bones about this i hope the us
women's national team doesn't win a game
i think they've done more damage to the
public comedy in the united states than
virtually any other sports team in
america
i i think that they have spent pretty
much all day
every day complaining about how america
is a terrible horrible place based by
the way on their own decision-making
recall they have this whole equal pay
routine first of all the men's world cup
is not the same as the women's world cup
the men's world cup is a multiple of the
size of the women's world cup second you
guys voluntarily signed a contract
whereby you didn't get a percentage you
got a flat fee that's your own fault and
then you complain
about how well you know the men get paid
more okay so you should have negotiated
a better deal
it's all performative nonsense and your
performative nonsense actually has
downstream effects for the culture
it turns out when the entire media
mirror the notion that megan rapano is
some sort of
horrific victim of american society that
all you're doing is promulgating a lie
it's amazing who's considered a victim
in american society these days truly
truly not the person who is working two
jobs
and is poor and is being harmed by
by outside forces not that person the
person who's really victimized is like
you know americans like megan rapinoe
meghan markle
jesse smolier like we have so many
victims in american society it's hard to
keep track of all the victims who make
lots of money
in the united states it's very hard to
keep track of all the victims like
lebron james like it's
so many victims who earn more money than
anybody could possibly hope to imagine
making
and have had honestly like the easiest
lives in america
and and yet these these are the victims
these are the victims man
so bottom line is honestly i'd rather
have a patriotic team
that loses than an unpatriotic team that
wins
so if the unpatriotic team loses i shed
no tears no tears
for a u.s women's national team and this
doesn't apply to everybody on the us
women's national team by the way not
everybody on the us national team i
assume
agrees with these sort of social justice
pandering woke nonsense
that megan rappano pushes but anybody
who decides that they're going to go
along with it
yeah i hope you lose i do end of story
how's this for a title ben shapiro show
subscriber destroys like button with
clicks and logic
i'd watch that make it happen gang